[Musique]
qunad bonsoir j'ai un cadeau pour vous
pour commencer
veuillez vous lever s'il vous plaît
et maintenant nous nous allons faire
tous ensemble une grande respiration
mais vraiment et encore une encore et
est maintenant à six et vous s'il vous
plaît
et maintenant fait
allez-y merci ça m'a permis de me
connecter à vous parce que la première
chose si on veut être bien ensemble
c'est très bien ensemble avec soi même
est ce qu'on oublie trop c'est que nous
avons un corps et ce corps fait partie
de notre vie
ils nous portent ils nous supportent et
nous dit beaucoup de choses et fait déjà
plusieurs fois par jour les grandes
respirations suivi d'un grand qu'est ce
que je vais bien merci mon corps et vous
serez déjà mieux avec vous même et comme
je vais vous exposer être mieux avec soi
même est aussi être mieux avec les
autres alors je me suis posé la question
en arrivant ici
quel est mon intention qu'est ce que je
voudrais partager avec vous ainsi tout
d'abord mon amour et mon ma passion pour
l'être humain est en fait rien après
destiné à être à faire ce que je fais
aujourd'hui parce que dans ma première
vie professionnelle j'étais banquier
allemand
j'ai appris à décortiquer les bilans
analyser des bilans a donné à octroyer
des crédits ou à refuser les crédits est
en fait aujourd'hui
donc là je m'occupais de l'argent
aujourd'hui je fais de l'art jean je
m'occupe de ce qui me passionne
comment mieux vivre ensemble comme lyon
comment mieux travailler ensemble et
j'ai fait un grand parcours
depuis donc mon entrée dans la vie
professionnelle en 75
parce que je suis en fait comme obélix
est tombé dans la peau magique je suis
tombé dans le fossé culturel
alors comment ça s'est passé parce que
en fait
en 1981 je suis parti pour cette banque
pour laquelle je travaillais à paris et
tout d'un coup j'étais exposé je parlais
pas très bien le français j'étais exposé
à les différences auquel je m'attendais
pas par exemple les français parlent
tout le temps de globalement exact à les
suisses comprennent pas ce qu'est exacte
des global ça va pas ensemble et moi en
tant qu'allemand c'était pareil
j'analysais un bilan pour moi c'était à
devait vraiment être au fait nique près
et mon collègue français en face il
avait plusieurs millions de différence
du must c'est pas grave c'est
globalement exact les français parlent
aussi de globalement positif et ça c'est
le mot magique que j'ai appris en france
au départ ça m'a dérangé mais in fine et
je peux dire que ça m'a accompagné toute
ma vie ce mot magique globalement et
donc c'est un peu l'entrée en matière de
ce que je voudrais partager avec vous au
travers des cultures aller vers soi même
à aller vers la culture de soi et donc
commençons par le relation donc au
départ ma croyance était les relations
si on comprend la différence culturelle
ensuite les relations vont mieux comme
vous allez voir ce n'est qu'une partie
de l'histoire
alors mon histoire a commencé à changer
parce que j'étais banquier dans cette
banque à paris place de l'opéra depuis
six sept mois et tout d'un coup il ya un
français collègues français qui viennent
me voir en disant you run tu peux pas
m'aider parce que là avec les collègues
allemands je n'y arrive pas on se
comprend pas et j'ai dit mais comment
vous comprenez pas parce que tu pas très
bien allemand ready c'est pas une
question de langue c'est une question de
culture je ne sais pas je dis mais
pourquoi tu viens me voir moi je suis
allemand comme lui ai dit non non non tu
n'es pas allemand c'est pourquoi toi tu
es sympa
et bien c'est là où j'ai commencé à
comprendre qu'en france les relations
sont différentes qu'en allemagne parce
que des premières 24 ans années de ma
vie j'ai vécu en allemagne
les relations étaient ce que nous
apprenons très factuelle donc dit à un
français ce que c'est les relations frac
factuel même ici en romandie
j'ai la même problématique parce qu'on
ne distingue pas l'être humain de la
chose
houda du travail qu'on fait maintenant
pour vous expliquer comment jusqu'où ça
peut aller
il ya quelques années je faisais un
discours en allemagne une conférence
devant des scientifiques et moi je parle
beaucoup avec des métaphores j'utilise
beaucoup d'humour et donc je voyais que
les scientifiques étaient assez
sceptique
et puis à la fin de la conférence
j'avais des applaudissements polis et
puis il ya un scientifique qu'ils lèvent
ai dit monsieur le broyeur vous avez
apparemment beaucoup de succès avec ce
que vous dites mais moi je ne vous suis
pas ça marche peut-être dans la pratique
mais jamais en théorie à la relation
factuel ça veut dire quoi
nous avons en allemagne qui séquences de
travail et des séquences de la vie après
la 5 à 5 heures nous avons un mot
magique qui s'appelle fayyad
vous avez déjà entendu ce mot voilà
soirée de fête
mais quand je suis allé en france on
comprenait pas ce mot qu'est ce que ça
veut dire français m'a dit mais en fait
à 5 heures l'allemand mutual êtres
humains
c'est une force de la culture allemande
de distinguer le relationnel est donc de
travailler de façon très dur et aussi de
se disputer deux façons de réduire mais
factuellement jusqu'à 5 heures ensuite
on se tape sur l'épaule
on va boire une bière ensemble on
s'amuse comme des fous et à 8h le
lendemain on est en train de se taper
dessus à nouveau sur le sujet qui nous
oppose avec c'est ce conditionnement
parce que la culture est un
conditionnement je pars donc à paris et
là j'arrive à autre chose ici s'il n'est
pas la compétence ou l'expérience qui
compte c'est beaucoup plus les unités de
pouvoir par exemple il ya une quinzaine
d'années un des entrepreneurs ou dix ans
chef d'entreprise des plus connus était
le ceo de la deutsche bank qui s'appelle
s'appelait broyeur et je peux vous dire
à cette époque là quand j'allais dans
des soirées ou des cocktails et je me
présentais your own péta broyeur les
gens étaient presque en garde à vous
devant moi en me disant ah vous avez des
relations avec monsieur monsieur roya de
la deutsche bank
si oui c'est mon oncle mais quand je
leur disais que non c'était une blague
avant la france est donc un pays où il
faut avoir du pouvoir pouvoir pour avoir
négocié par exemple donc si vous avez
son unité de pouvoir et l'autre n'a que
80 mais vous négociez pas parce que vous
avez le pouvoir comme vous venez d'un
pays communautaires comme l'allemagne ou
ici en suisse c'est incompréhensible
mais c'est ainsi maintenant il ya quand
même une façon de remédier à ça et ça
c'est faire de l'esprit
si vous n'avez pas de pouvoir la seule
façon de travail des français wild
d'être bien avec eux c'est de faire
l'esprit je vous donne un exemple
j'étais à paris chez un client récemment
j'étais légèrement en suisse et je
demandais ce monsieur me présenter à la
machine à café aux autres ils vivent à
la rue raimbault ailleurs c'est un
allemand qui a vécu à paris
et maintenant il est en suisse et qu'est
ce qu'on vous dit du tac au tac en
france à vous est parti avec notre
trésor dit ah oui bien sûr j'ai emmené
ma femme a très bien et tout de suite
l'ambiance a changé donc là c'est la
complicité qui ce cri la relation secret
par la complicité
en suisse c'est le pays du consensus
on va y aller gentiment sajoo pour vous
alors quand vous venez de france vous
êtes un peu perturbé les pour contre
qu'est-ce qu'il est toujours gentil mais
je vois pas du tout suivre alors de là
maintenant je vais vous emmener vers un
autre pays c'est le pays de vous même
parce que je croyais que les cultures
était le principal obstacle à la
compréhension de l'autre que durait et
finalement j'ai découvert que c'est la
culture personnelle qui était le plus
important est ce que c'est la surprise
que je vous ai emmené aujourd'hui c'est
de vous découvrir trois pays trois
couleurs et c'est là aussi vous allez
carton que vous aurez vous allez pouvoir
utiliser tout de suite
en fait vous avez le pays bleu dans un
pays bleu on aime anticipées on aime
planifiée on aime maîtriser dans le pays
vers on aime agir ensemble c'est la
relation qui est important la
communication sincère et la convivialité
ensuite il ya dernier pays c'est le pays
rouges agir rapidement prendre les
risques et obtenir très rapidement des
résultats concrets
vous avez déjà certainement fait votre
choix
dans quel pays
si vous aviez le choix sachant que vous
avez les trois pays en vous il ya
personne ici dans la salle qui n'est
uniquement dans un pays si vous avez le
choix
quel est le pays que vous dans lequel
vous préfériez vivre agir travailler et
donc je vous invite de maintenant de
découvrir vos propres dès que le bouton
déclencheur qui vous font agir qui vous
motive
donc je vous donne vraiment 10 secondes
les v votre votre carte on peut peut
être mettre un peu de lumière voilà et
de voir un peu si si la sai la y en a 3
vais très très peu de rouge
beaucoup de verts et vos coups de bleu
et bienvenue en suisse parce que des
vinées si je fais le même exercice en
france
à votre avis qu'est-ce qui va remonter
de plus voilà eh bien je voulais faire
je voulais vous faire faire un petit
exercice mais le temps nous manque
malheureusement mais c'est pas grave je
vais vous expliquer parce que je voulais
vous faire faire vous rencontrez vous
retrouver parmi la même couleur et
d'échanger sur vous êtes parti chez ikea
vous avez acheté un meuble et maintenant
vous êtes à la maison où vous allez
monter ce meuble dans un pays bleu
comment on fait dans un pays vert comme
on fait et dans un pays rouges
alors commençons par les bleus les bleus
vont prendre de carton délicatement
l'ouvrir sortir le mode d'emploi
lire le mode d'emploi sortir lévis
compte et lévis
et quand il ya une vie ce qui manque
alors ikea mais surtout pas commencer à
monter le meuble parce qu'on n'a pas les
moyens pour monter le meuble le rouge
alors ils montent de cartons claque
ils ouvrent rapidement ils sortent ou le
mode d'emploi
je vais le faire moi même parce que je
suis très intelligent il ça va beaucoup
plus vite comme ça et en vingt minutes
ils manquent ils montrent le meuble sauf
que c'est un peu de bon car même si les
français du c'est pas grave c'est
globalement hockey en suisse ça va pas
en suisse ça doit être quand même précis
dit rouge en suisse il dit pour ikea
c'est vraiment plus ce que c'était a et
donc réclamation peut se regarder dans
le vôtre carton maintenant le nom du
tout j'ai déjà j'étais le garçon carton
mais regardez mais il va regarder il
trouve la vis manquante est un peu vite
maintenant les verts ils sortent avec
les bars le carton mais dont la voiture
est déjà dans la voiture qu'est ce
qu'ils font à l'eau les copains j'ai une
caisse de bière
vous venez monter le meuble avec moi
voilà ce que je raconte là sur le trône
ohmori stick est un problème aux devient
un problème où il n'est pas un problème
quand tout va bien mais dès qu'il ya des
conflits d'intérêts dès qu'il ya des
tensions mais on a un problème de
travailler ensemble
rien ne sert d'attendre on se
débrouillera ouais ça c'est le rouge
rien ne sert de courir il faut réfléchir
avant d'agir
ensuite il ya le vert qui arrivent en
disant pourquoi se disputer prenons
d'abord un verre trois mondes 3 talons
trois façons différentes de travailler
ensemble
problème c'est que ces coopérations peut
devenir cas aux opérations et là ça fait
naître des viraux émotionnel et quand
l'autre se tombe mais en fait il n'est
pas très bien mais moi je suis content
que l'autre tombe
nous appelons sa rentrée en intelligence
protectrice leur être bien ensemble avec
l'autre c'est d'abord être bien ensemble
avec soi même ce que j'aimerais vous
évite invité aujourd'hui c'est de
découvrir vos bouton déclencheur que ce
soit suisse thaïlandaise anglaises
américaines chinoises
donc nous avons des bus bouton
déclencheur culturel et c'est très bien
il ya aucun jugement possible là dessus
parce que une culture fonctionne
toujours très bien dans son propre
environnement culturel sauf que quand on
va travailler ensemble et ce stress tout
un coup toutes ces différences peuvent
devenir les obstacles et prendre
conscience qu est ce qui déclenche
qu'est ce qui me motive
quel est mon talent par rapport à
l'autre vous et des rares à être mieux
avec l'autre parce que l'autre est une
chance pour faire la paix avec vous même
plus vous êtes conscient de vous même
mieux vous serez avec l'autre et je
voudrais vous révéler pour terminer la
phrase qui m'a accompagné depuis je
crois que c'était en 86 car que j'ai
entendu cette phrase et c'est mon
dernier cadeau pour vous si vous
respectez cette phrase vous allez voir
ça va changer votre vie
ce que tu déranges ans l'autre n'est pas
clair on 3 bronze et toujours comme vous
pointer un doigt sur l'autre vous
pointez trois doigts sur vous même merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]